pourquoi est-ce que pluton n'est plus
une planète pas à la réponse courte
c'est à cause de ce mec là michael brown
michael monde qu'est ce qu'il a fait il
a découvert une nouvelle planète
la dixième planète du système solaire
qui l'appela eris mais l'union
astronomique internationale refusa de
faire des ris une planète
ça c'est parce que si on fait des lices
une planète bien il ya encore plein
d'autres objets qui mériteraient eux
aussi la terminologie de planètes les
alors on se retrouverait avec des
centaines des milliers voire des
millions de planètes et personne ne veut
apprendre les millions de planètes du
système solaire parquet du coup l'union
astronomique internationale a répondu
non kerry ce n'est pas une planète
et comme vous pouvez l'imaginer michael
brown n'était pas content avec cette
décision
comment on fait ok qu'est ce que l'on a
goûté mais si mes soins possibles dans
ma mairie ses plus gros comme plutôt que
c'est plutôt est une planète
et oui c'est forcément une planète aussi
chaude c'est une molette soit python
n'est plus une planète
en fait c'était pas très compliqué de
trouver des raisons pour lesquelles plus
tôt on ne devrait pas être une planète
ont commencé plus ton est plus petit que
ben la lune la lune
peut-on autre chose l'orbité de pluton
est assez bizarre
et quand je dis bizarre on va vous
regardez déjà ce dessin vous voyez que
les autres sont quasiment des cercles et
tout ton nom et puis pouvoir regarder
aussi ce n'est sans là où vous voyez que
les to sont tous d'un même clan là sont
tous bien naviguer tous dans les rangs
et pluton bas il fait n'importe quoi
autre chose plutôt à un satellite charon
c'est grand comparé à lui en fait charon
est tellement grand comparé à pluton que
pluton tourne autour d'un point
imaginaire qui est le centre de gravité
des deux planètes
simultanée est donc plutôt est tellement
petit qu'il est grandement affectée par
la 13 hectares de son satellite et ça et
d'autres planètes
ça leur arrive pas en fait les autres
planètes elle est long agglo mére toute
la masse qui étaient autour d'elle elles
ont un peu passer l'aspirateur autour
d'elle c'est pour ça qu'elles sont aussi
grosse et surtout quels sont les seuls
êtres aussi grosse dans leur voisinage
il n'y a pas d'autres planètes aussi
grande que la terre ou comparable à la
terre autour de la terre ça ce n'est pas
le cas pour pluton qui est entouré de
milliers de millions d'objets qui ont
plein pas mal de similarités avec pluton
et ça c'était l'argument clé de l'union
astronomique internationale pour
justifier le fait qu'elle ne considérait
plus plutôt comme une planète
mais pour moi le meilleur argument
contre le statut de planète de pluton
vient du fait de sa composition en fait
plus ton est à moitié un énorme bloc de
classe de glace fait 7 e classe d'eau
mais aussi de classe de méthane et de
glace de nitrogène toujours est il que
toute cette classe quand elle est
exposée au soleil
elle commence à pondre et en fait c'est
plutôt se rapprochait du soleil si
pluton était au même niveau que la terre
par rapport au soleil bas de pluton
fondre est un peu un peu comme une
comète en fait plutôt en fait c'est un
peu plus une grosse comète que un truc
comme les planètes du système solaire
est ce que vous en faites le plus humain
dans toute cette histoire c'est que tout
ce qui arrive plus tôt aujourd'hui est
en fait déjà arrivé à d'autres planètes
dans le passé ça nous est arrivé à céret
ce palace junon restos
connaissait pas quelques planètes que je
viens de citer sont des planètes scène
où des petits objets qui se trouvent
entre mars et jupiter et dans le passé
c'étaient les seuls savent bien qu'on
avait observé dans cet intervalle
du coup on se disait très naturellement
que ces objets avaient le statut de
planète et du coup à l'école à l'époque
on apprenait les onze fait du système
solaire la connaissez pas encore les
chaînes donc il y avait les sept autres
planètes du système solaire
plus ces quatre planètes qui aujourd'hui
ont été reléguées au rang de
d'astéroïdes pourquoi parce que un peu
comme pour plus tôt aujourd'hui on a
trouvé énormément d'objets semblables
dans la même zone
et du coup on a le cul entre deux
chaises soit on dit que ces objets sont
des planètes et du coup il faut rajouter
tout un tas d'objets qui sont similaires
à re donc j'ai peut-être une dizaine
voire une centaines voire des milliers
de nouveaux objets et de les répartir en
tant que pnj système solaire ou soit on
prend la solution peut être plus simple
qui consiste à dire que tous ces objets
là on est au monde dans une ce qu'on
appelle la ceinture d'astéroïdes et on
dit que ce ne sont pas des planètes de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui pour plus
tôt et très similaires à ceux là sauf
qu'au lieu de parler de ceinture
d'astéroïdes on parle de la ceinture de
qpr et là il espère quand même que j'ai
réussi à vous convaincre et que plutôt
fait ça a du sens même de dire que ce
n'est pas une planète et que c'est juste
un des objets de la ceinture de cuyper
en fait la question qui est intéressant
c'est pas tant de savoir pourquoi est-ce
que pluton n'est plus une planète ça à
peu près évident et on en fait quoi
c'est plus une planète qui ce qui est
intéressante c'est pourquoi est-ce que
ça a été une planète et ça ça nous
ramène à l'histoire des planètes
parce que pendant longtemps
ne pas observer beaucoup des planètes on
apprend aujourd'hui à l'école en gros on
connaissait six planètes balle à mercure
vénus la terre mars jupiter et saturne
en fait ce sont les six que ont peu à
peu près voir les nus dans un ciel bien
dégagé et à s'éloigner d'une grande vide
est en fait au xviiie siècle un certain
william à auch à regarder dans le ciel
la nuit avec des outils beaucoup plus
puissants que ce qu'il y avait avant et
l'a vu un objet brillant dans le ciel et
ses toiles bas donc les bras au ciel
oui c'est une étoile après tout de là où
on est tous ceux que l'on voit est un
point lumineux nos anciennes noir mais à
y regarder de plus près ce point
lumineux bougeant fait par rapport au
fond cosmique et ça c'est ce que font
les planètes pas les étoiles du coup
uranus 8 enfin au connue comme la
septième planète du système solaire
et enfin on en vient la partie vraiment
intéressante à savoir les scientifiques
ont commencé à étudier la trajectoire
d'uranus et ils ont observé qu'elle
semblait ne pas totalement suivre les
lois de la physique tout cas la loi de
la physique de l'époque les lois de
newton et du coup certains commencent à
suggérer que les lois de newton n'était
plus vrai des distances aussi éloignées
et donc au dix neuvième siècle alors que
les mesures de 13 victoires d'uranus
était de plus en plus précises ont
commencé à vraiment douter des lois de
newton
à moins qu'il y avait une autre
explication plus ontologique plus il
existe quelque chose qu'on n'a pas
encore observé
genre un objet une planète qui perturbe
la trajectoire d'uranus et autour de
1845 un mathématicien anglais appelé
john adams a commencé à pouvoir
localiser la position dans le ciel de
cet avion qui perturbait un tracteur
d'uranus du coup il a appelé
l'observatoire de greenwich et on lui a
fait un peu un fugueur écoute bonhomme
c'est bien voter descend sur un bout de
papier mais nous
des gens sérieux on observe le ciel on
sait ce qu'on fait quoi là pour le coup
john cage adams pas de vols quoi il
aurait pu être su qui a découvert
neptune mais non la gloire est plutôt
venu un mathématicien français robert le
verrier qui a fait exactement la même
chose que john cox adams et mais sauf
qu'il a appelé lui l'observatoire de
berlin il leur a dit regardez à cet
endroit là vous allez voir un objet
brillant et c'est la huitième planètes
du système solaire
et puis ils ont fait bon ben on va
regarder du mec a découvert une nouvelle
planète sur un bout de papier quoi si ça
c'est pas la classe et du coup neptune
et découvertes
et ça ça veut dire qu'on peut tuer avec
leur donner une thune la 1 re belote
très coordonnés tu ne suis pas
exactement les lois de newton
du coup peut-être que il ya un truc qui
perturbe c'est très lent et que une
neuvième planète dans le système solaire
ils ont regardé le ciel ils n'y ont
contemplé à leur recherche de ce point
lumineux qui bougeraient ils ont vu un
truc c'était pas très lumineux et ça
bougeait pas beaucoup mais avait l'air
de pouvoir peut-être être planète
du coup les observations n'était pas
folle mais a comme l'histoire se
répétait man legends croyez pas mal an
l'observation et du coup bah ils ont
rappelé ce petit truc qui bouge
peut-être qu'ils appellent brillant mais
qui a l'air d'être quand même quelque
chose dans le ciel pluton g au fur à
mesure que les observations de plus pour
s'améliorer qu'on a une meilleure à
meilleure estimation de plutôt bien se
rendre compte que la taille de pluton
était sincère ce surestimé à tel point
qu'il ya un papier qui est sorti qui
prédisaient la disparition à venir de
pluton en fonction des estimations de
taille publiées dans la littérature au
cours des différentes années comme
laisse saver le bas et vers le bas ça
veut dire taille proche de zéro donc
c'est plutôt a été une planète c'est
uniquement à cause des méandres de
l'histoire des méandres extrêmement
confus où les extrêmement facile de s'y
perdre
mais des méandres qui font toute la
science je pense que trop souvent la
science est vu comme quelque chose de
fini et habib forgée dans le marbre et
une forme que si on voit la science en
tant que tel et ben est vite déçu des
sciences et on trouve rapidement que ça
tourne en rond et que c'est juste de
l'apprentissage par coeur
alors qu'en fait ce qui est vraiment
intéressant en sciences ce n'est pas
tant le fait de savoir des choses c'est
le fait de chercher à comprendre des
choses de toujours aller plus loin dans
notre compréhension quitte à remettre en
cause des choses que l'on a pensé dans
le passé et cette recherche scientifique
est extrêmement dynamique ces jours ci
pour preuve il ya seulement six mois
une sonde humaine explorer pour la
première fois de l'histoire
voisinage de pluton s'agit de murs
résonnent qui a quitté notre planète
il y a dix ans déjà je trouve ça juste
incroyable et puis les images de la
sonde
c'est juste un plaisir à regarder c'est
juste trop trouve la recherche
scientifique continue également d'un
point de vue théorique avec la
suggestion par notamment michael brown
d'une vraie neuvième planète du système
solaire d'un vrai objet massif de la
taille de neptune ou quelque chose comme
ça l'eau fin fond mais vraiment très
très loin dans notre système solaire
dont pour l'instant on n'a aucune
observation directe ce qui est bien
c'est que la raison pour laquelle
michael owen et ses collaborateurs ont
suggéré l'existence de cette neuvième
planète c'est en étudiant les
trajectoires non seulement de pluton
mais aussi de tous ces objets qui se
trouvent dans la ceinture de cul père et
leur trajectoire à certaines
particularités qui ont amené michael
brown a expliqué celle ci avec
l'existence d'une seule planète qui
permet donc expliquer plusieurs
trajectoires de plusieurs objets et du
coup ça permettrait de refaire un lien
avec l'histoire est peut-être que si au
20e siècle on n'a pas découvert de
nouvelles planètes et un peut-être qu'au
xxième siècle on en découvre à une et ça
je trouve ça bah ça ce sera super recul
j'espère que vous avez vu cette vidéo
sur pluton
j'aimerais revenir sur les commentaires
de la semaine précédente
pour la vidéo sur pie vraiment un
commentaire de vie la vie qui se pose la
question est-ce que six puits contient
tout ce qui contient le meuble est ce
que les gens puissent aux troupes dans
ces décimales la réponse est non parce
que leur fait payer un nombre infini
voir les décimales
et du coup le fait que ce soit un nombre
univers dis seulement que toutes les
tous les nombres fini que toutes ses 6,8
fini de nombres ou de deux lettres sont
prenables abbas 27 se retrouvent dans
les décimales de pi mais ce qui est
infini ne se retrouve pas forcément dans
les noms de donald duck et en fait on
peut même se poser la question quels
sont les nombres qui se contiennent
elles mêmes on se rend compte que pour
que ça soit le cas il faut que le nombre
avec les décimales de ce nombre en fait
se répète puisque si on ne retrouve plus
loin faut que la séquence bureau soit la
même qu'en partant du début et donc des
décimales qui se répète ça yaya n'y a
pas énormément de possibilités
il faut que ce soit des nombres de la
forme en fait de motifs qui doit avoir
un tweet de dison n chiffre ou une
lettre qui se répète ensuite
indéfiniment et donc si on multiplie sa
part la bonne puissance de la bad en
base 10 x 10 kg en scène sinon multiplie
sa part discussion s'anime ont retranché
lui-même on obtient exactement ce motif
la donc ses nombreux là qui se répète
indéfiniment seront de la forme x / elle
moins 1,9 ou x et entre 0 et 9 9 où il
ya et de -1 9 donc l'exemple de base
basse et si je prends et légalement et
le jeu xla
j'obtiens alors la fraction un neuvième
et un dixième s'écrie un point 0-0 et en
couleurs on voit bien son oubli de 0,1
plus qui est parti pour avoir ce
nombre-là contient lui-même puisque si
on oublie les cinq premiers chiffres et
ben on obtient à nouveau
l'uac corps vers agit aussi comme
auxerre de stephen weiss qui est sûre
fric pivi soit décidée la valeur depuis
soit décidé par référendum
en fait c'est pas vrai la valeur de pi
n'a pas été décidée par un serveur web
c'est un problème quand même super
important depuis les politiciens ou tôt
les sénateurs de lydia n'ont pas fait
passer sa part référendum ils ont juste
votée ça à l'intérieur du cénacle donc
c'est juste passer la loi entre
sénateurs entre politiciens et donc ils
y apprennent à face était passé à
l'unanimité puis après il ya un matériel
qui est passé dans la salle il ya un peu
expliqué avec le monde parce qu'ils
étaient en train de faire et puis bon
j'étais c'est un lot après avoir été
traité de ridicule front tant par le new
york times c'est quelque chose comme ça
il y avait de quoi
sinon je vous remercie aussi tous vos
autres commentaires qui sont super
positif et je suis vraiment content que
cette fois en vidéo vous et plus ils
espèrent que cette vidéo deuxième vidéo
s'il va vous plaire et que plus
généralement les vidéos à venir
on vous plaira que vous allez en
particulier abonnés à cette chaîne et
que vous regardez beaucoup de mes vidéos
la prochaine fois on va parler de
pourcentage la question et qu'elle
aimerait que vous réfléchissiez c est ce
que l'on peut ajouter des pourcentages à
un privé sur la une augmentation de 5%
suivie d'une augmentation de 1%
on va dire qu'on a eu une augmentation
de 6%
est ce que c'est vrai que c'est pas ce
que c'est presque vrai
c'est complètement faux c'est ce que
j'aimerais que vos avis hier une fois et
puis comme vous allez voir ça va nous
amener à parler de choses assez un crâne
comme les développements de limiter le
fait que rien utopique je vous les
étapes
on va y arriver or ce que j'espère que
vous avez aimé encore une fois cette
vidéo que vous allez lalique et que vous
allez la partager commenter aussi si
vous avez des trucs à dire sur
l'addition des des pourcentages ou sur
pluton et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois coup la nasa envoie 67
encore une planète
mike brown n'a donc pas tuer plutôt
comme son pseudo l'indiqué mais il a bel
et bien été à l'origine de son
déclassement